one of the major trends related to this
area is the convergence of technologies
for media consumption account for this
trend with reference to relevant
technologies providing examples specific
comment no this is the second time that
you had the keyword account for all
right so I'm gonna mention it again
because it was so disastrously done
right account for means account for the
boiling water that's in the kettle in my
kitchen when I wake up in the morning
okay account for that
well account for means provide the
reasons the the causes for how this
happened right so I've got the HSN email
with my house and I wanted to make a cup
of tea so that's the account for right
that's my reasoning it would not be a
county for a first and now that I've got
a cup of tea
sorry a kettle of boiling water I can't
do XYZ right so you've got your kettle
of boiling water in the middle right
account for me it's give me the causes
that led to that most people said well
now you've got this thing what can you
do with it okay now that we've got all
this convergence with technology what
are the results okay so you totally miss
the question and even though they were
coming marks on it there were four marks
on a lot of people got like a maximum of
one or two because you just missed the
point the question right so what are
some of the answers which I was
expecting things like network
connectivity network connectivity okay
how could we get this convergence of
technologies like say people using their
phones phones which are for calling
people right how can they use it for
things that are traditionally on a
computer like sending emails and that
kind of thing well because you're
freaking out on the internet right so
network connectivity is being built into
all kinds of devices and the lowering
prices of modem hardware and even the
increasing prevalence of like cheap
broadband and cheap cellular data it's
really cheap this got a mobile phone or
whatever with cellular Dino
anyone how much does it cost like per
month roughly thirty yeah is that we
think witty calls and that kind of thing
yeah is that about the same roughly
cheaper more spit sue 20 yeah I was I
suppose it depends on who your handset
with a and how much clothes you've got
okay that's 20 bucks a month that's
really cheap for what you guys it's like
I can just get to I can communicate with
the entire world through this thing
that's in my head anytime I like right
so really really cheap suits for
fifteen-year-old you know I can do it so
a lot of people so that's how remember
I'm trying to account for this trend
it's big trend how's it possible so
network on TV right and that allows
phones and gaming consoles to become
media consumption platforms meat
consumption platforms right so you can
say things like Android iOS Windows
Phone those are actual examples right
account for this trend with reference to
relevant technologies so you guys say
what they are right and if you said
gaming consoles where you gonna name
them right say Playstation or Xbox or
whatever so network connectivity is my
first point secondly miniaturization
what does that mean just a big fancy
word miniaturization ironically it's a
big word what does it mean mid Nietzsche
or ization I have no idea how to spell
it's it's something like that yeah
that's pretty close it means I can make
big things small big big so you guys see
the pictures right of how big computers
used to be there used to be the size of
the room we're in right and now they're
really tiny their handheld or they're
this little box in your living room
right so miniaturization of what let's
be a little more specific powerful
processors right really really powerful
CPUs you can build it very small okay
graphics cards high performance screens
right I don't know if you remember when
the iPhone 4 was released there was a
massive press thing about the whole
retina display field right so you need
to say specific things now
probably you don't have to smell this
these right these are specific these are
specific display technologies and we can
make them really really small and we can
make them really really high-quality
right so this allows for the convergence
trim just picture this okay imagine if
we have network connectivity in all of
our little devices right but our little
devices have really really sucky screens
who's gonna want to play games on it
who's gonna want to watch YouTube videos
of community channel whoever you watch
youtube videos oh or you know
good-looking bridge twins or whoever if
if your screen doesn't put out a good
image right so these kinds of things
make the trend possible yeah so you can
really see how this trend sorry this
technology sort direction accounts for
this trend okay then give you another
one connectivity miniaturization that's
making things small but some things are
getting big how look at the screen
you're seeing in front of them right the
screens of all of us in your front those
are really quite large compared to the
first computer screen I had it was a
13-inch cube thing right and you can you
could beat people to death with it it
was hilarious so there's a really tiny
screen so when you used it you literally
were sort of like $100 and even you know
there was like eight colors on the
screen not six eight point seven million
okay so what's my point this is number
three the increasing size of displays
for things like pcs right and the rising
quality of you know even computer sound
systems right you get a really nice set
of set of speakers for your PC now it
enables desktops and even to an extent
laptops to compete with home cinema
systems people are watching stuff on
YouTube and they're like I don't need to
watch it on TV and there isn't the
argument like well but on TV it looks
better
well maybe even maybe not it might look
bigger but it's pretty big on the
computer screen already right how many
people idle away their hours on YouTube
because their computer screens are good
enough to watch
but TV shows and you know other channels
oh right okay let's say I got a few more
I actually let me come back to the UM
network connectivity one let's put a
some point under here now the network
connectivity one is important because
allowed the second screen phenomenon to
rise second screen now you can put that
in quote marks if you lack who's heard
of second screen before second screen
yeah maybe okay so this is something you
should have picked up in your research
right second screen is about I know if
you were watching say the voice who
watch the voice i watch the voice okay
I'm too old right yeah look that it was
good music I thought it's good music for
the most part now one of the things they
had was they had an official iPhone iPad
app right and what they did was they
encourage you to look at it and use it
while you were watching enter in the
address right I don't know how the
people who bought ads for The Voice felt
about that but anyway so the second
screen phenomenon is I am I'm sitting
there in front of my TV right but I've
got this network connected device in my
lap and I'm you know I'm on Twitter or
whatever I'm watching video back screen
backstage interviews that kind of thing
while my TV's going okay that's
antipathy again and that's convergence
am i watching TV or am I on the Internet
well I'm both that's what convergence
means right so you got tablets and
smartphones and then providing
interactivity and social connections so
it's a new kind of trend right so you
could say The Voice app that's that's an
example of this hmm
what else let's see talking about now
this one here okay
sorry this last one I talked about
convergence people going on to their
computers to watch TV you see how
convergence is this right one of the
other things that accounts for that is
that new platforms like like YouTube
like Hulu those kinds of things they're
prioritizing content on demand there's
the key phrase content on demand right
rather than scheduled programming rather
than I've got to turn up at 7:00 p.m. so
I can watch my show okay it's more like
we go I really like this show and I'm
subscribed to it and it comes on when I
like and then
can watch it whenever okay I can watch
it at 11 p.m. at night when everyone's
gone to bed that kind of thing if I like
so yes so the increasing size of screens
or the quality of screens right that
allows us to get content on demand in a
very you know sort of viewer pleasing
fashion okay
okay now let's see okay let me read this
one for you this is kind of like a
miniaturization issue which is that
things which now is used to take up lots
of space can now be put all into one
device okay
so from an end user perspective right
there's a convenience aspect when things
are small you can have it all in one
device so here's my sub point under
convenience right having less devices
and embedding social media into those
devices it's a really compelling user
experience okay really compelling so
what that means is rather than I've got
two things I watch TV and then I go and
talk to people which is two separate
things about the TV show I enjoy right
now I do on YouTube or on your Facebook
and you're watching that video and then
you comment right away okay my wife she
really enjoys what is a loser's okay I
don't know that's it's a pretty old TV
show so but it's not old in terms of
like it was a long time ago it's on down
but it's for old people anyway but the
thing is what she does at the end of
every show she's always going on
Facebook and watching the preview for
the next next week's clip and then
talking that out to everyone on Facebook
about oh I can't believe this character
did that night can you believe they died
and so on and so forth okay morning so
it's a really compelling user experience
having all in the one place or she
doesn't on her phone and she can she can
watch next week's preview and she can
talk to people about you know what the
what the TV show is doing okay so that's
really interesting so you're
incorporating lots of different services
into one device and that's part of
miniaturization